do it anyway is a mindset trick that you
can use when you start to feel excuses
rolling up it works a lot like the
five-second rule if you've got to do
something that really makes you nervous
or that you're afraid to do before
you're about to do it come up with an
anchor thought my life changed a couple
years ago when I discovered something
called the progress principle wanna soar
get a mentor
[Music]
hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel is created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you you've
got Michael Jordan level talent at
something so today let's learn from one
of the best Mel Robbins and some of her
best mindset tricks to destroy worry and
excuses mentor me Mel
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with real number
one do it anyway do it anyway
is a mindset trick that you can use when
you start to feel excuses rolling up it
works a lot like the five-second rule
so you have said to yourself okay I'm
gonna talk to my boss today about that
thing that I've been avoiding talking to
them about or maybe you've said
something like I'm gonna go to the gym
today or tomorrow whatever and then the
moment comes where you've got to have
that conversation or the moment comes
where it's time to pack up your bag and
leave your desk and go to the gym and
what always happens you don't feel like
it I bet there are plenty of you
watching that have made a commitment
that yeah I'm not gonna have a drink
tonight and then guess what happens when
you get home you don't feel like not
drinking you feel like having a drink
and so here's what do it anyway has done
for me the idea that I just do it anyway
has pushed me to realize and to
recognize that there are a lot of
moments where there are things in my
life that I really want to do I need to
do I should do but when the moment comes
I don't feel like it and so I pull out
this idea of you know what I'm just
gonna do it anyway it's raining outside
I said I would go for a short run I
don't feel like it I'm gonna do it
anyway it's six o'clock in the morning
I'm tired it's cold I laid out my yoga
clothes but now I don't feel like it
what do I do I do it anyway when you
start to say to yourself I'm gonna do it
anyway
happens is something really cool you
acknowledge that there are feelings that
you have that are trying to swoop in and
hijack you you acknowledge them and you
basically say guess what I'm gonna do it
anyway
rule number two use a brain dump so
let's pretend that this right here this
empty mason jar is your brain in order
to do your best thinking you need to
make sure that you've got the full
capacity of your brain leveraged and
pointed at the things that are important
to you here's the problem when you go
through life as you go through life what
happens is you know your brain starts to
fill up with information and that's what
creates a state of feeling overwhelmed
being overwhelmed is nothing more than
having a full brain so as you go through
your day-to-day life and you start
checking email and looking at texts and
looking at Facebook and sitting in
meetings and flipping through television
channels and sending emails and writing
Excel spreadsheets and running and
picking up the kids at work and getting
another text and looking at Instagram
and looking at Twitter and checking out
the news your brain gets pretty full
doesn't it and so when you feel
overwhelmed what I know about you is
that your brain is full of a bunch of
garbage and so oh I didn't think about
the drain draining I hope that's not
bothering you but it's certainly gotta
bother me what you need to do in order
to fight overwhelm is you've got to
actually do a brain dump you got to get
rid of all that stuff so that you've got
an empty brain so you can focus again so
how do you do that it's easy to do with
a cup of water because you just pour it
up this is what you're gonna do you are
literally going to dump out everything
that's in your head onto this piece of
paper every concern every worry every to
do every thing that's bothering you that
you're thinking about you're gonna write
down
[Music]
all right and when you're done writing
down everything that's in your head and
there's absolutely nothing left Oh got
something due tomorrow that I kind of
forgot about once you get that stuff all
down on a piece of paper pull out a
highlighter take a look you could do
everything on this list you could but
what should you do what are three things
just three that you should do in order
to advance the things that matter to you
let's see I got to do that one I gotta
do that one and I got to do that one the
rest of this list is complete and other
garbage it's other people's stuff it's
the email stuff it's the meeting stuff
it's the stuff that's not all that
important to me it's not that
mission-critical
so by dumping everything out I now not
only have the three things I need to do
I've got a clear head so I can get it
done also if you want to have more
confidence checking my 254 series
they're free the links to join are in
the description below when you have an
intention on something that you want to
change about your life your brain helps
you you might want to get honest with
yourself like instead of doing this be a
millionaire or do this
do you really because you can make it
happen
you actually can look at all the idiots
that are making money you can make money
in order to get to the next level in
your business you got to decide right
now what habits do you have as a leader
that you have to change now rule number
three use anchor thoughts if you've got
to do something that really makes you
nervous or that you're afraid to do
before you're about to do it come up
with an anchor thought what's an anchor
thought well an anchor thought is
something that's going to anchor you so
that you don't escalate any situation
into a full-blown panic attack or into a
situation where you screw things up it's
a way for you to anchor yourself so you
maintain control over what you're
thinking and how you behave so here's an
example with flying it's important when
you're creating an anchor thought to
pick something that
is in the proper context of what you're
afraid to do so for flying pick an
anchor thought that has to do with the
trip that you're taking so if I'm
boarding a plane to fly back home to
Michigan an anchor thought might be a
picture in my mind of my mom and I
walking on the shores of Lake Michigan
where I grew up that's a thought that
makes me happy it makes me excited and
it's also related to the trip that I'm
taking if you have a conversation that
you need to have with your boss pick an
anchor thought about how you feel after
having that conversation maybe it's you
picking up the phone and calling
somebody that you you love and saying oh
my gosh it went so well or you know you
walking out of the meeting and feeling
like yeah I survived that conversation I
feel pretty good about myself so now
that you have your anchor thought you're
ready to beat the fear how you're gonna
do it is this so let's go back to the
example of the plane I'm on the plane
applying to Michigan we hit turbulence
my body's gonna start getting agitated
right I'm starting to get nervous my
heart starts to race one of two things
can happen I can't control how my body
might feel but I can always always
control what I'm thinking about and I
can always control how I act and so can
you
so when I'm on a plane and the
turbulence hits 5 4 3 2 1 that's step
one and it's essential and the reason
why using the five-second rule 5 4 3 2 1
is essential is because that is how you
switch the gears in your mind you awaken
your prefrontal cortex and you trigger
your brain that you're now in control of
your thoughts you've interrupted the
fear you've settled your thoughts and
now your brain is ready for that anchor
thought so then what I do after I go 5 4
3 2 1 is I insert the anchor thought
that I've already come up with before
the flight I start thinking about
walking on the beach and being with my
mom and my dad and I start telling
myself I'm so excited to walk on the
shores of Lake Michigan I'm so excited
to see my parents
now something remarkable is going to
happen in your brain because you've
interrupted the
fear and because you've used the
five-second rule to assert control and
awaken your prefrontal cortex and
because you have an image that can
textually make sense to your brain
because you're flying to Michigan you
know your brain does your brain goes huh
Mel's excited to go to Michigan because
my body is in a state remember the first
fact fear and excitement exact same
thing what's the difference between fear
and excitement what your brain is saying
using the five-second rule in an anchor
thought you can actually switch the
gears in your mind and reframe the
thoughts of fear into thoughts of
excitement and because you have a vision
that makes sense based on what you're
doing your brain buys it you just
tricked your brain and rule number four
the last one before a very special bonus
clip is use the progress principle my
life changed a couple years ago when I
discovered something called the progress
principle it is a principle that was
written about in the Harvard Business
Review it's based on a tremendous amount
of research done by a professor over
there and what she determined is that
people that feel happy and successful
and fulfilled by their lives and work
they all have one thing in common they
feel as though they're making progress
on something that matters so I read this
little bit of research and I started
applying it to my life and what I do as
as stupid as it sounds it really works I
don't focus on balancing everything I
focus on just making sure that I make
progress on one thing a day that's right
you heard me one thing a day that
matters to me now if I can make progress
on one thing a day that matters to me
then I can let go and let the rest of my
day get hijacked by kids by spouse by
phone calls by emails by social media by
all kinds of things that come up and
tend to hijack your day when you're a
busy person when you have a family when
you're married when you got a lot going
on and so by focusing on one thing a day
I feel the sense of control in the sense
of progress that science tells us will
make you happy and make
feel more confident and actually make
you more effective at getting things
done it also frees me up to be more
present with my kids now have a special
bonus clip for Mel on how to use the
five-second rule that she's so famous
for I think you're gonna enjoy it but
before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching a video to taking
action here we go
question number one how can you apply
the progress principle to yourself today
number two what do you we need to just
do anyway
and number three when will you schedule
a brained up in this week and if you're
gonna take immediate action after
watching this video give me a hash tag
believe down in the comments as well so
the five-second rule is a self coaching
tool that's all that it is and it's
something that I invented literally 20
feet from here in my bedroom although
that bedroom wasn't built back then it
was something that I invented to beat my
habit of hitting the snooze button
mm-hmm and the way that it works is very
simple
the moment that you need to do something
and you can feel yourself hesitating and
you can feel the excuses rolling in
count backwards to yourself 5 4 3 2 1
and something weird will happen the
moment you get to one you'll actually
move and I invented it by mistake I
invented it during I think the worst
moment of my life which was 2008 Chris
and I my husband of 22 years we were
about to lose everything
well his restaurant business was going
under I had just been fired from a job
my first job in the media business so I
was just wallowing and self-doubt
because I thought boy have I really
screwed up I had changed my career
taking a risk gone into the media
business it didn't work out I felt like
a total loser I felt like I made a big
mistake we had three children mortgage
to pay the entire house had been used to
leverage the business so it our life
savings so at the kid's college savings
I mean just on the verge of losing it
all Chris was sleeping on the couch and
I just couldn't get out of bed and
so I invented this bang the five-second
rule one night when I saw a rocket ship
fly across a television screen at the
end of a commercial and it gave me this
idea and the idea was hmm I wonder if I
launched myself out of bed so fast I
wonder if I could move fast enough that
I could beat the self-doubt and anxiety
that I felt every single morning when I
would wake up and it was really that
dumb and that simple of an idea and for
whatever reason when the alarm went off
that next morning what happened is what
happens to all of us all day long
inspiration strikes so the alarm goes
off and used the thus knew who used the
alarm clock as a metaphor for those
moments when you know you should do
something and the alarm goes off and
what's interesting is most of us don't
have a problem with what we need to do
it's how we make ourselves do this
that's hard so the alarm went off and
immediately my mind woke up and my mind
started spinning as our minds do and I
started immediately thinking like most
of us do when the alarm goes off I don't
want to get up on is you know it's cold
I don't want to get the face a day I'm
an employee and then the body starts to
kind of get a little tense when anxiety
comes in or you start to feel
overwhelmed about this you got to deal
with and I felt myself reaching for the
snooze alarm like I always did but that
morning I went 5 4 3 2 1 and by the time
I hit one I was standing up and I was
kind of freaked out because why would
something so simple work but I went on
with my day
and I used it the next morning and the
next morning the next morning and then I
started to wonder god I see that it
works as a cheat for the alarm clock but
I wonder if it could work for other
things so I started to use it for every
moment in my life where I knew what to
do but I didn't feel like it 5 4 3 2 1
literally just decimates any excuse that
you have
as I started to use it in my life - five
four three two one not be an [ __ ] -
Chris five four three two one turn and
walk away from the Bourbon and not have
a drink five four three two one pick up
the phone and network five four three
two one walk out the door and go to the
gym everything changed because my
decisions changed
if you want more Mel Robbins check out
the top fifty rules video I made on her
the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there our minds are designed to stop you
at all costs from doing anything that
might hurt you